I'm a debride I'm a reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
looking at I found something really bad
and I have been taken
look around at the world who do you see
a planet on the brink of collapse human
beings are disposable like man and
symbiote combined this is the new race
your species a higher life-form
me
[Applause]
we cannot just hurt people
we have a team I like clear so many
threads from the time
to that power it's not completely awful
you have no idea how much you're scaring
me right now
and you just might survive guys you do
not want to do this trust me
leaps
we'll always come at a cost
[Music]
right ahead you will be this office will
be rolling down the street
[Music]
oh I have a parasite yeah
neighbors Jen you told me the story of
the war when the ground shook in the sky
burn
of the ones that survived who awoke to a
different world
or the powerful right but that's not the
way it has to be when I found you
you're very human brain was miraculously
it's the loneliest feeling not to know
who you are in time you'll remember
[Music]
Oh
the leaders doing here it's horse world
down here you gotta be willing to do
what it takes to run
[Music]
Mika's she's the last of a kind
she contains technology that have been
lost for 300 years
let me show you something
[Music]
this body I feel a connection to it I
can't explain you know more about me
than you're saying
if he does some things have better left
forgotten and I'll find out for myself
she's threatening the natural order of
things I need you to destroy her leader
they will come for you I'll have to face
them head-on
tonight is not a good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm with her my father was a lighthouse
keeper
my mother was queen but life has a way
of bringing people together could unite
our birds one day
check it out author is talking to the
fish
they may be what I am
listen to come aboard
[Music]
I've been looking for you your half
brother King arm is about to declare war
upon the surface world
the only way to stop this war is for you
to take your rightful place as king
trust me I know you
do your best thinking when you're not
thinking at all that was the worst pep
talk ever
I want to strap in
my brother has come from the service
Charles Mead for the throne
my god an ass-whooping
no leader
James I have no choice
I can't save my home
the people that are loved you think
you're unreadable lead which is your two
different worlds
that is exactly why you are worthy
was awesome
the war is coming to the surface
and I'm bringing the wrath of the seven
seas with me
[Music]
what are you doing a parachute right
hoods
[Music]
[Music]
prepare their ceremony we blessed enough
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me tell you something
a driver on picnic on
car picked the driver so mrs. kebab
between man and machines of mystical
bomb
between man
[Music]
who are you do you speak order you
[Music]
what's your name
[Applause]
you got people out there we'll need you
this is why you're here be
and OB music can help you say what
you're feeling
try this
[Music]
[Applause]
it's amazing to meet you it is simply
extraordinary
maybe this will all make sense if I
explain Who I am my name is dr. Ellie
staple and I'm a psychiatrist my work
concerns in a particular type of
delusion of grandeur it's a growing
field I specialize in those individuals
who believe they are superheroes good
for you the three of you have convinced
yourselves you have extraordinary gifts
like something out of a comic book David
Dunn the only person to survive that
trainwreck all those years ago what do
you do I'm in security you think you
have superpowers
it's a feeling vision I have to touch
them you believe you are a protector
my name is Patricia I have no question
there are two dozen identities I'm Mary
Reynolds senior we almost got to that
live in that body with you Abby it's
common any minute now for you guys
but what I am questioning is your belief
that you are something more than human
being and yet it is true my bones break
easily and I've had 94 breaks in my life
but you have an extraordinary thank you
this is not a cartoon this is the real
world no way and yet some of us still
don't die with bullets
some of us can still bend steel
I've been waiting for world to see that
we exist may I meet the beast I hope for
your sake that he likes you that sounds
like the bad guys taming on a lot of
people are going to die I don't do this
are you ready
what do we call you sir first name mr.
last name our world is changing the mass
extinction we feared has already begun
and we are the cause we are the
infection
[Music]
but like all living organisms the earth
unleashed a fever to fight this
infection its original and rightful
rulers the Titans for thousands of years
these creatures have remained in hiding
around the world
and unless all the titans are found our
planet will perish and so will we
they are the only guarantee that life
will carry on
[Music]
you're goddamn on I am sorry but this is
the only way
[Applause]
[Music]
long live the king
[Music]
that
is London
sixty minutes is all it took to bring
humanity to the very brink of extinction
mankind mobilize a new age arose the age
the great predator city's survival of
the fastest
Hey
Hotel Valentine this is for my mother
stop
ask him what you murdered my mother
I'm sorry you had to header as to Sean
she won't stop until I'm dead unless you
kill her first
I want them found
I've been looking for you for a long
time
your mother she said she had found
something dangerous she was afraid of
Valentine of what he might do mine who
controls this controls the world she
said that you could stop him
this weapon can wipe out the largest
city in the blink of an eye
not if we shut it down
nothing can stand in the face of this we
have to stop London before it destroys
us
I'm sure you want to do this once we go
in there's no going back
I have to
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can take care of myself when
you're 18 give these people a chance
because that's what they're giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it it gets
real Game of Thrones around here dude
just mess around you look at me and
you're like why so dark you're disabled
foster kid you've got it all if you
could have one superpower what would you
think everybody chooses flight you know
why so they can fly away from this
conversation no cuz heroes fly well you
need your fake family to stand up for
you hey man sorry about that
Billy Batson
I choose you
escape you
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir
are you for real okay
Shazam Billy you're the only person I
know that knows anything about this Cape
Crusader stuff tonight yeah that's crazy
right what are your superpowers
superpowers dude I don't even know how
to pee in this thing fly
[Music]
okay
why are you talking
you know I don't think that's gonna buff
out your bum stars your phone charge
help teach like a bad guy right
you have full immunity foolproof you're
dead welcome we're not getting robbed
okay stop I'm a superhero cute
neurodegeneration or I ate nearly 90% of
the country's children are now survivors
of the virus develop side effects or
what some are calling powers unexplained
incidents involving surviving children
continue to pour in from across the
country now go live to president grace I
am speaking today as a parent we'll find
a cure and save our children if you can
hear this you're one of them
if you're one of us the government's
afraid of the ones who live but we don't
have to stay in darkness
the only ones who could help us are us
[Music]
we're ready for you
find us at darkest minds on Instagram
and Twitter
[Music]
soon there wouldn't be any kids anywhere
the government wasn't afraid of what
happened to the ones that didn't make it
they were afraid of us because the ones
that survived changed Lu Bu are very
rare among its the most powerful
we're going to a place where kids can
live together on the outside the only
people who would ever help us for us
whatever happens don't stop for their
safety in yours please turn over your
children this morning to know you're
hiding something and you're smart enough
to be hiding
I just want you to be afraid of me more
that I try to control it
more damage that I do
I can show you how to use your strengths
the way they're meant to be used
[Music]
we can fly back
we don't have to stay in darkness
we've survived all of this
I will fight for all of us
[Music]
[Music]
do you know what my job description is
I'm in acquisitions I look up and I
catch what falls out of the sky
[Music]
tell me about the mission did you see
anything unusual it's above our bakery
[Music]
look I get it
something went down in Mexico nobody
wants any witnesses we need to know if
you and your man pose a threat
we're Rangers it Baxley if your mom's
vagina were a video game they'd be rated
E for Everyone there's an opposing the
three kind of the [ __ ] point
[Music]
predators just don't sit around making
hats out of rib cages the conquered
space but that's not what's on the
horizon should I be worried Riley I
think you know what is on the ship the
ultimate predators
we may die
we're still here
so come and get us [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm gonna ask you a series of questions
I want you to respond truthfully have
you ever heard someone
yes have you ever experienced anything
you'd consider abnormally
yes
less question do you know a mutants are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous and adult once they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here
[Music]
what is this place this is in the
hospital haunted house
[Applause]
you're being through hard get some rest
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you